on this episode I invite the interns
[Music]
you ask
this is
ask Gary B everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 130 of
the askgaryvee show it's a gloomy
Tuesday here in New York City like we've
had pretty good weather this summer like
I was caught off-guard when I left my
building it was like pouring I think
didn't even look at the weather I've
been been taking it for granted I was
reminded this is not San Diego this
morning so no taking for granted I look
at my weather app tomorrow morning Matt
it's coming with my phone that excites
me ah really excited to be back on the
show uh this is a very special episode
this is the internet so three interns
are gonna sit with me today who have
spent their summer at vaynermedia and
ask me a question I'm excited about that
India is here Sid the intern is here as
well I said you should actually ask a
question let's do four you're in now no
so four intense Gila ask me a question
uh what else is going on
I'm starting to get serious about my
snapchat game I tested a little bit
yesterday I thought that was pretty good
I see some head shaking so that's good
I'm excited about what I was doing there
which will be scary because I think
people will now get a real sense of how
much traveling I actually do if I got
through there so it looks likes me uh
what else the wine deals Instagram
account has been very much in right-hook
zone Emily thank you for following the
account and you know what you may be
also able to ask a question I do need
five questions so we might as well just
do that Emily's not an intern but she'll
explain who she is when she gets on the
show so uh so I get I don't even know
like India like what are you just gonna
hang and just watch what they are I
didn't earn some dinner I can do this
with you and the other right interns
let's get into the show
cool who wants to come up first how
about good
got a kick off with the fellow cheque
fan yes absolutely I'm excited you ready
for this season ah
you could start about all the injuries
don't worry I'm not happy tell the
vaynernation who you are vaynernation
I'm Russell I am a die-hard jet fan lash
like Gary I go to USC um
[Music]
what else without me um I'm gonna listen
anything you can do to show how great I
am on camera is so it's something to
kick on the way to kick up way to kiss
up to the books
alright so uh so uh good summer yeah
great summer it is last week yeah are
you we're done crazy when you back to
slur I go back on Saturday excited so
we're back up pumped yes very big year
that football team is actually gonna be
good so I'm actually optimistic are you
yeah I need to watch them play a couple
preseason games there's a couple key
things I'm looking for on the offensive
line and at the linebacker position but
I think I could be optimistic we'll see
alright well Gina but anyway um I guess
for diving well the question um has
there ever been a point for you where
you've kind of been overwhelmed with
options for where you want it to go kind
of in your career and life and what was
the thought process and the
decision-making process you went through
when you ultimately made a call
I think it's happened more unlike what I
think you're going with your question as
you're younger you may be in school
there's a lot of options you know to me
I was set at your age right I was I mean
I barely went to college I was like I
that badly wanted to go into the family
business and do my thing where I started
having these things happen really is
more of like the last five to seven year
phenomenon where I'm crippled by
business options do I want to be a
venture capitalist do I want to start
companies do I want to do more econ do I
want to do TV shows like I've had a lot
of options in the last five to seven
years and I think for me
you know there's a cup what I like to do
is run on two parallel paths so here's
my piece of advice one I'm constantly
debating them right and you just have to
you're human being you're thinking about
your options
but I'm always doing something I think
the thing that bothers me is that people
are crippled by their options and then
actually aren't doing anything in
parallel they're lallygagging while they
decide and to me whatever you're
deciding given that these should all be
loaded questions whatever's in your
option point you need to be doing
writing the exit
so if there's three to four tangible
things going on in your mind you need to
make sure your internships your free
time you know whatever you can do to let
you taste them and get context around
them is what really matters
good sorry that's it good right awesome
I think there's gonna be follow Wow um
in terms of of that I mean that makes
that makes a lot of sense just it's
about it's about execution right like to
me what I was doing was I've showed up
on TV a lot I did ancient high ran
vaynermedia like I was doing all these
things I think people I think people
confuse that you could be doing a lot of
things at once if you're able to stretch
that rubber band but how much of it
would you say is like following your
passion versus kind of like trying new
things and experimenting and seeing I
would never try anything that I'm not
excited about mmm like to me when I hear
you say following your passion literally
what I heard is how much it is is it
about oxygen like to me that's the only
thing like everything I just mentioned
are all things that I'd want to do like
you know how many people ask me to go
into politics I don't you right so so
but I don't want to do that and so I've
never pondered that right and so you
know to me you know teachings
interesting I think I'm a modern teacher
I like it I love this uh but I don't
want to do it I don't want to do it in
the way that USC actually wants me to
teach a course the guy that I came and
did that course for he's like look we'll
set it all up for you you can be a
professor and there was a part of me
like my mom would really get a kick out
of that but other than that I'm like I
don't want to do that and so all of it
has to do with passion but you can have
passion about a lot of different things
so to me if you're contemplating
anything that's practical or money based
get the hell out let go I deal with
finance I make more money that's like
that I think that is a terrible idea
awesome cool cool enjoy myself real
pleasure max hey kiddo how are you good
how are you tell the Vayner nation who
you are hi I'm Sabine I'm the core
insight intern and I'm also a co-founder
of Linnet and I love the plug yeah d-roc
give her a little
all right oh yeah really you can't
prepare I promise you they're gonna love
the hustle all right okay so my question
is hypothetically speaking yes
ah you need a co-founder of a startup
one can I or that person do this
hypothetical presence you to meet their
team for five minutes um a minute well
you got I'd be more than happy to do for
you
and in general it's just a little bit of
serendipity I get asked all the time I
get pounded all the time like living my
life like going to school functions with
my wife or parties or just living life
right now I am fully in I get pitched
mode right which is for me super
flattering I'm humbled that I've hit a
status where that's what people want
from me and so my money or my time or
attention or points of view all of it is
still humbling and interesting so you
know for you that's a done deal to
schedule that for everybody else who's
watching they've all tried I've got I
there's people who are watching right
now who emailed me 90 times who hit me
up on social media 90 times and who will
never get that at-bat it's literally
just the serendipity of it all there's
other people on their first email or
their first tweet or the first you know
thing get that at-bat I have so much
volume that I have no real way to truly
have a system my vayner/rse has a
structure where you can definitely go
through that process and it can
eventually get to me but you got to go
through the fields and sean's of the
cabins the Bryan's and Khloe's and so um
you know that's it that's the answer I
think one of the really smart strategic
ways hypothetically is to actually get
an internship at vaynermedia let's put
it down you're putting good work finagle
your way into
the askgaryvee show were on the spot in
front of the vaynernation you can ask
the question which then compels me to
actually do it that would be that would
be something that I would consider
mounds like a very smart person who
should hit up Malthus to it I love it
sit mind my guy said tell they know you
a little bit but given the official IRA
donation I am said I've been working
with team guy for the last ten months
I'm a graduate student at Babson and my
question is a little bit around you
because like how in-depth I've seen you
working and I've seen you go all-in when
you're like doing something but then I
we also as a team have seen that you
step back and see things in a wider
perspective and then you change
direction come up with creative ideas so
how do you decide when it's like moment
to just step back and reconsider that's
interesting question um you know it's
funny you know I always say the
candidates when I meet with that meeting
with a lot of senior people are going to
run a lot of departments here at Manor
in the future and I say look you know me
in the outside and you think that I'm
gonna micromanage a ton what's weird is
I'm very the other way like I actually
have a lot of you know it's you know I
was want to ask
I always really want to reverse this to
the ask sit show cuz I'm curious how you
quantify for to mean this is a very hard
answer for me because it's just innate
right like it's just how I don't even
know meaning
yeah I mean I feel when I have to go
deep I feel like when I have to go wide
I'm reacting to what feels intuitive to
me of the moment I'm quantifying the
people that are involved in the
situation the market it's it's a you
know it's kind of like a feeling to
understand what to do at that moment
what I think what I think happens is
when I taste it I talk about I use the
analogy like blood in the water sharkman
right when I taste it then I want to go
all in right like that I'm like let's go
right and so but I don't know how to
quantify what it takes for me to taste
it I feel like it's a combination of me
and my partner-in-crime
team or individual is now at a crescendo
to like be able to really attack it and
I can like really go in and there's like
a cadence between the two of us that
allows us to deliver on an INT you know
sit I think that's a [ __ ] answer and I
apologize there's some answers that are
just toughed ik you know like it's just
how do you describe the feeling but I do
believe this is the essence of what why
I always believe that entrepreneurship
and being a business man or woman is a
talent this question hat is the same
question of like you know like how do
you know when to hit the high note like
when do you know it's game time and
you've got to shoot and stop passing the
ball like like you know when do you know
like how to like like being a great
surgeon like like where do you like like
it's just the feel and the rhythm of the
game and as a businessperson I've said
this Emily you might have heard this
like and some of you guys might have
heard this I've been saying to a couple
people here there that the company feels
more manageable to me like right now I
feel more in control of four offices in
550 people than I did when we're at 200
it's just it's it's the rhythm of it and
so that's why I know it's a talent
there's nothing I was taught there's no
blueprint it's um it just being one with
the business but it's what it is
it's like it just I understand it and
you know what's funny I don't think it's
right or wrong I think what you're
observing and I know you've been very
observant which is why it was a fun
question to hear from you it's right for
me do you know what I mean it's not the
right thing that you need to go and
deploy against you and it's not right
for your startup it's what's right for
me and what's what the one thing I do
love about myself and this is just
flat-out I don't let any but nobody has
any equity from my parents
my brother to to my most trusted
employees
nobody has impact or can wait make me
waver or dense that belief in me and it
and that thing and that unwavering has
brought me an enormous amount of value
it's just like it's just the strongest
thing in my world like me and the
business at hand you know in harmony
without allowing any other voice to even
have a peep in that direction has been
very very important to me cool all right
keep going that's a good episode intern
hey how are you I'm good let your chest
hair thank you
we're gonna travel to appreciate it tell
the other animation my name is Michael
I'm gonna be a senior at the University
of Michigan I am a DJ a huge dance music
enthusiast love it so for the last
interim question only a little deeper
with you okay
so I want to ask what setup it was that
dig it SID see what pretty deep okay
we're gonna go in like a different level
though that's good okay so I want to
know how you define love and what that
means to you and how that personal
definition affects your relationships
that's a very good question I actually
this one's actually very easy for me
it's something that I got to in my mind
love is very easy for me love to me is
actually shifting your brain or your
feelings into a place where you value
the other person more than yourself like
the people that I love I truly truly in
general I'm a pretty epithet ik like you
know really care about the other
person's point of view and how do I
bring value but that whole 5149 thing
that I talk about from a business
standpoint which a lot of you know what
I'm referring to but people are watching
for the first time or others that don't
know it's hey give 51% of the value in
the relationship you'll always win when
it comes to the people that I love I'm
very comfortable in being at a
zero when I make that shift when I fell
in love with Lizzy to my kids my parents
my siblings Brandon my best friend runs
Wine Library those core couple of people
that I would say I love I'm very
comfortable in providing the entire
value in the relationship that the thing
that it's crazy the more I love you and
this has actually been something that
I've struggled with in my life but it is
absolutely how I define love the more I
love you down the chain is the more that
I is the level of which I want less from
you
so like the people I love the most I
literally don't want anything from I
want to provide so much disproportionate
value I want to never make myself a
burden or something they think they need
to deliver on and I want it to be I want
to be the first person they call and the
person that they most rely on and Trust
in the world and as my love goes down
that goes down to just maybe even um
that's how I define it I like it call me
up okay thanks thanks for your summer M
hey how are you well so Rini you've got
a lot of energy whoa
let me see your shoe oh oh I'm going to
show you how we do it surimi it's like
like a pop of color all right here we go
so yeah okay
yeah it'll side by side stylish shoes
yeah we match the urban your head I've
always got an element yeah tell the
vaynernation hi I'm Emily I work on the
vaynermedia communications team I'm very
excited to be there it's some
interesting stuff that we're doing and I
led the internship program this summer
so all of these characters that are in
here somehow I had an actor
to get the door it's been been amazing I
think it's awesome this year that we had
insurance in different departments so
not just all social media interns we had
people in studio doing copywriting doing
interesting things like team Gary's
though it's been an awesome experience
cool ah so my question is kind of around
ah career growth yes and how you map
that I heard you say recently that your
30th birthday you freaked out and
started Wine Library TV and I thought
that was interesting thing to map back
was that the start of a hockey stick
that you kind of went on I know you
talked about turning 40 and how that's
very exciting how do you yes
a la I might just disappear I'm excited
yeah um how do you see store like
milestones like that like an age or
something like that and sort of like
career and comparing yourself
so it's or like we should be I don't
know if I'll ever have anything like 30
because 30 was a real kind of
interesting moment for me because I
really really felt for the first time in
my life on my 30th birthday that I would
not buy the New York Jets or that might
be you know you know and I think look
this is a good time to talk about it if
like if it's confusing to anybody I'd be
very okay if I don't mind in your jets I
want to buy the New York Jets but more
importantly I want the process of buying
the New York Jets and what hit me was my
behavior wasn't acting towards a process
of buying the New York Jets that I was
starting to become complacent which was
very weird for me and it scared me a
little bit like I'd made it right and
and by everybody else's definition and I
loud in a world where I very much we
talked about in SIDS question live in my
little world for some reason that you
know obviously I got married at the day
before my 29th birthday so Lizzie was
new in my life like whatever it happened
in those two or three or four years from
26 to 30 it was the the most complacent
version of myself I mean I'm not
dramatically more of a hustler today
than I was at 26 which is tough because
I have children and a marriage and I'm
like
him I mean this would have been a much
much rather worked it out which is why I
push that objective so much in people's
20s that's when you that's when you
don't go for the cash that's when you
sleep on the floor right like with 19
people in like this room like Jerome
Jarre slept at vaynermedia right like he
cost yet now he makes millions of
dollars being Jerome Jarre if we can
slept here like I like I know what it
takes and I so anyway I don't know why
I'm gonna left-field birthdays are
interesting you've had some big
birthdays receipt birthdays apart these
are interesting for me I'm definitely
freaking out about my 40th birthday like
because what's happening in my brain
right now is like 40 to 50 is the
foundational decade of like you know
like if I don't really crush back that
gate and there's a part of me that
laughs at me because that I'm like hmm
now I'm gonna come to 50 be like all
right is it's clear like this is where
you really go to moguls like like I know
my some self-aware enough to know that's
how I'm driven I have this equal push to
like massive ambition and equal
understanding of myself knowing that the
goals that you know it's funny I can't
wait to be a public figure in my 60s 70s
and 80s and talk about there's a weird
part of me and it's an emerging weird
part that says wow I can make a bigger
impact on the world if I don't buy the
Jets because I could talk about you know
the satisfaction that I have in that I
gave it my all and I you know there's
serendipity and there's other variables
or that you know this you know like you
know I'm a weird dude this tragic event
happened and I just did my priorities or
this incredible thing happened let's
look on the bright side and I know my
son was a whiz kid violinist and I
decided to deploy against that you know
so I think that the way I think about it
is for me birthdays or beer
I definitely milestone birthdays 30 and
40 is ripping me right now and like 30
did and so 50 rail and so and I don't
know how I'm forcing that narrative or
not but the real but I think um I think
that they definitely make me think about
things Andrea just like I'm sure the
cliche thing that I'm sure it happens to
everybody but I didn't have them at 18
or 21 or 25 it started 30 for me and
probably speaks to what I'm ambitious
about I wasn't as much worried about my
childhood or things of that nature um my
career has been the the beacon of my
life outside of my family and that's
what I don't I don't associate myself
with you know like being a party dude or
like getting the most out of my twenties
it was more career oriented um and so I
think it's different for everybody and I
think you know it also speaks to you
know these big birthdays are also a
tremendous important time to reflect
around family and health obviously took
care of my health I've been spending a
disproportion amount of time on my
family hacking as happy as I am with the
extremism of the weekends and vacation
time I'm starting to bubble up some
other thoughts and so I think you know I
think it's fun being a human like it's
fun to hang out with the interns here
who are like starting to go to that next
chapter where like the game they've
played their entire lives of school
infrastructure is going to go away and
they go into a different game and and
that's interesting to watch and and it's
interesting that my parents are
interesting to watch to me you know you
know there was something I read that
said you know when you save money your
whole life you you don't know how to
spend it so I'm watching my parents
struggle to relax and enjoy this next
chapter of their lives and so like I'm
very observant as a business person
around psychology but also is like a
human I'm interested in how people roll
and I think the best thing I can say is
you know go with what feels right um
attach yourself to a couple principles
that matter the most and I let the cards
play out as they will Thanks cool it's
deep deep you know yeah I didn't know
the intern was gonna get so deep I guess
that's it good nice and nice and kind of
tight I mean the answers are pretty much
hey thanks hope you enjoyed that show I
really did I really enjoyed it it was
weird not to interact with you
whole bunch of you feel kind of myself
but don't worry now the golden era is
ended
we'll get back to like engaging on 131 a
question of the day tell me a story
about your most impactful birthday you
know tell me about your year that made
you think or you did something this is a
good opportunity for the community to
get to know each other more obviously
there was a post I posted on Facebook
over the weekend that allowed you guys
to kind of like talk about yourselves
and bizdev and boy did you take me up on
it
and it was great to see the community
interact with each other I think for
Facebook and YouTube comments lurkers
this would be a tremendous time to come
out and tell us a story about you the
birthday the signature birthday so far
in your life and a little story around
it you keep asking questions I'll keep
answering why don't you guys come over
here next to me and then I'll do the
intro with you guys in it actually you
know what want you guys to stand and so
here I like Nick the shot like of that
man and then go up to them funny all
right dry hey it's good right what
director
[Music]